salut romain ça va c'est bon t'es prêt
pour le hellfest ah ouais je suis prêt
voiture est comme ça 6 pourquoi on slip
la nouvelle épisode de notre série
highway to hell fest
aujourd'hui on va apprendre à éviter les
pièges et les dangers en festival parce
que oui ce que je vous dis là c'est vrai
pour le hellfest et c'est valable pour
tous les autres festivals
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais ce que vous dites vous dit
un festival c'est pas dangereux qu'est
ce qui vient de faire flipper autre
conte alors déjà vous allez me parler
sur un autre ton ah oui évidemment on
parle d'un festival de musique on n'est
pas dans sur l'album mais c'est donc
tout ce qui est bon si on veut pouvoir
en profiter à fond
faut quand même prendre quelques
précautions parce que vous le savez
aussi bien que moi
bon vivant rinne avec brive rien donc ce
que je vous propose c'est dresser la
liste des ennemis potentiels et des
moyens d anéantir parce que ça serait
quand même dommage de laisser un petit
détail gâché trois jours de fête
le soleil meilleur exemple du truc super
cool à la base mais qui peut tenir et
ton bonheur si tu fais pas attention et
cela pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
ça chauffe
ensuite parce que ça brûle donc les
coups de chaleur et les coups de soleil
alors les règles d'or c'est ne restait
pas en plein soleil tout le temps allez
vous mettre à l'ombre de temps en temps
il ya des coins qui sont prévues pour ça
et cette année où elle fait ce qu'ils
vont mettre encore plus de brumisation
parce que l'année dernière il a fait
bien bien chaud et en plus c'est plutôt
agréable
protégez-vous la tête surtout un chapeau
ou une casquette ce que vous voulez mais
protégez-vous et la peau aussi avec une
bonne crème solaire achetés en pharmacie
rafraîchissez-vous l'intérieur et
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire buvez de l'eau
fraîche régulièrement et mouillez vous
la tête ou votre couvre-chef pour encore
plus de précision je vous renvoie aux
vidéos que j'ai fait sur ces deux sujets
les coups de chaleur et les coups de
soleil
je vous mets les liens dans la
description les entorses voilà elle fait
c'est comme 99% des festivals en plein
air c'est dans les champs donc pas sur
un terrain plat che plat surtout après
quelques heures du coup le risque c'est
de coller le pied dans un trou et de se
tordre la cheville
par exemple ça va tu as mal et je me
tordu la cheville
prévoyez des bonnes chaussures qui vous
tiennent bien la cheville à titre
personnel je vais opter pour ce modèle
mais bon il ya l'embarras du choix
vous avez bien trouver chaussure à votre
pied prenez ça au sérieux j'ai discuté
avec le responsable des secours du
hellfest les ententes c'est une des
premières causes d'intervention pendant
le festival avec les petites plaies le
soleil dont on a déjà parlé et avec
l'alcool à
[Musique]
nous y voilà bon on va pas faire les
hypocrites on va jouer franc jeu vous
allez boire de la bière c'est ça bon
alors c'est évident mais je vous le dis
quand même parce que je sais comment ça
se passe ne fait pas n'importe quoi
vous avez toute la journée pour boire
des coups et pour faire la fête
commençait doucement si vous voulez voir
la fin mes petits conseils perso manger
je parle pas de 3 chips et de cailloux
est mangé des bonnes grosses plâtre et
qui tiennent bien au corps genre des
pâtes et surtout manger avant de
commencer l'apéro après c'est trop tard
savez ce qu'on dit
buvez de l'eau entre chaque verre
d'alcool en verre d'eau minimum l'alcool
saïd rate pas sa déshydrate
alors en plus avec le soleil de l'eau ça
vous évite au mieux la gueule de bois et
problème musculaire au pire le coma
éthylique
faites des pauses l'apéro ok mais un
apéro de 72 heures
votre corps n'est pas vraiment équipé
pour en plus c'est comme tout encore
meilleur quand on se retire un peu vous
avez compris l'idée c'est pas de faire
tout le hellfest à la taupe elle encore
que si vous avez envie pourquoi pas mais
l'idée c'est surtout ne pas se gâcher la
fête en voulant trop la sphère et
décibels alors voilà encore des super
bons potes pour faire la fête mais qui
peut vous faire du mal si vous faites
pas attention si vous voulez pas avoir
d'acouphènes penser aux protections
auditives
alors vous pourrez en trouver sur place
évidemment mais vous pouvez aussi
acheter celle qui vous conviennent le
mieux
avant de partir ils en font même des
moulé sur mesure n'apporte donc mettez
vos bouchons et ne restez pas coller aux
enceintes pendant trois jours vous aurez
vous dire merci
là encore je vous renvoie à ma vidéo sur
le sujet je vous mets le lien où vous
savez la poussière qui dit chaleur qui
dit chan qui dit meute excités qui
sautent partout et qui laboure la terre
dit poussière alors en soit ce n'est pas
dangereux
vous respirez bien pire toute l'année si
vous habitez en ville mais quand même ça
peut irriter
alors si vous voulez éviter d'avoir un
bac à sable dans les bronches et des
crottes de nez qui ressemble à de la
roche volcanique
prévoyez un foulard ou un masque prenez
un truc style est en tant qu à faire
[Musique]
la crasse oui on va en parler parce que
l'hygiène en festival c'est une vraie
question
alors non ne pas prendre une douche tous
les jours c'est pas un problème en soi
alors vous le savez déjà si vous avez vu
la vidéo sur le sujet je vous remets le
lien en bas rend fou mais ne pas se
laver du tout pendant trois à avoir
quatre jours alors qu'il fait chaud on
transpire etc
il ya un juste milieu vivant les odeurs
corporelles
c'est aphrodisiaques les organes
génitaux qui sentent les gambas à vous
de voir en gros pour éviter les
irritations l'idée c'est de nettoyer les
zones où les bactéries se développent
facilement
c'est à dire celle où la macération leur
permet astuce c'est facile à reconnaître
c'est là où ça sent mauvais donc si vous
n'avez pas accès aux douches ou si vous
avez la flemme de faire la queue
l'avez-vous au moins les aisselles les
organes génitaux l'arrêt du cul et les
pieds et le visage un temps 12e et les
dents aussi pas forcément dans cet ordre
si vous des petits mots lingettes bon
disons pour l'environnement c'est pas
idéal pour la peau non plus d'ailleurs
le mieux ça reste l'eau et le savon
l'égoïsme et l'individualisme c'est
mauvais pour la santé
vous avez compris c'est une façon de
dire prenez soin de vous évidemment mais
prenez soin aussi des autres en gros si
vous voyez quelqu'un qui s'est endormi
au soleil par exemple ne laissait pas
cuire si vous voyez quelqu'un qui a
besoin des aides qui se met en danger
avait lui filer un coup de main et
surtout n'hésitez pas à prévenir les
secours si besoin au hellfest qui a un
poste de secours sur le site un autre au
camping et de secouristes qui se balade
un peu partout on appelle ça des
maraudes
il ya aussi des médecins et des
infirmiers qui sont spécialement formés
en cas d'urgence et surtout les
festivals il ya des équipes qui sont
prêtes à intervenir
donc n'hésitez pas les petits bonus il
va peut-être faire très chaud mais il va
pleuvoir aussi renseignez vous avant de
partir et dans le doute pensé à fourrer
dans votre sac un dos et ravissant petit
punch quand vous allez voir énormément
notamment de l'eau parce que
tout à l'heure pour pas perdre votre
gobelet pensez à emmener ce petit objet
extrêmement pratique qui existe aussi en
modèle tour de cou si vous préférez la
trousse de secours
vous avez remarqué là on a fait le tour
de tout ce qu'il fallait faire ou de
tout ce qu'il fallait emporté pour
éviter les ennuis
mais bon pas toujours tout prévoir donc
il faut aussi penser à remporter
de quoi soigner les bobos en cas de
souci une trousse de secours
mais ça ça mérite une vidéo à part
entière donc je vous propose d'en
reparler une prochaine fois
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos en attendant prenez soin de vous
et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]